welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and today it is such an honor to be
with ms marvel kamala khan herself the
first to be identified of a certain
beloved category of marvel superhero in
the 616 mcu or is it 616. we'll talk
about that we got iman valani here with
us today thank you so much for chatting
with me iman welcome thank you this i am
so glad i got experience the welcome
back to new rockstars intro let's
dream come here man
amazing well this is a dream come true
for us too we're obviously a huge uh fan
of you here on this channel this is
actually the first time we've had an
avenger with us in the blue dungeon well
are you an avenger can we call you an
avenger is that okay oh
i i consider myself one no one's
granted me the the access to calling
myself that but we'll see
yeah
how how does someone get knighted an
avenger we saw you know tom holland get
like the united thing and you know
people like us are like okay so that is
definitively how one becomes an
adventure then i know there's some sort
of initiation process it's it's all in
kevin feige's mind now yeah uh and i i
just also asked because like i i don't
know i don't go on cruises but people
are like going on cruises seeing videos
of you with anthony mackie and they're
asking me to break it down and i'm like
i don't know what this is i don't know
what it is
we shot it like i i got to london to
film the marvels last year and it was
like the first thing we shot as soon as
i got out of quarantine and everyone was
so confused what we were filming
they just like handed us the script and
then put me on some green boxes and i
was like jumping from one thing to
another and like talking to anthony
mackie's recording um it was weird it
was fun but weird yeah i think that's a
testament to uh to how well you are
handling this you know marvel actors are
not given enough credit for the
the guessing game that you all have when
you're cast on these things and the fact
that you just look so calm and collected
and confident in the way that you're
playing kamala and just look like you
are in on the loop and part of the plan
and it seems like there's no confusion
at all in the way you've been doing this
i i feel like i've prepped my whole life
for this i think you're part of that
reason now that i think about it just
like the theory breakdowns the trailer
breakdowns the poster breakdowns all the
breakdowns i feel like the youtube nerds
are the backbone of this fandom you know
let's actually talk about your
background a little bit because you know
obviously you're the first of many
things in the mcu again congratulations
on on how well you've been doing it's
just been a delight to watch you on the
show uh and i think part of the reason
we love you here at new rockstars is the
fact that you are a bit of an egghead
like we are like you know i think you
might be the first true mcu fanatic to
actually get cast as a marvel superhero
you know a lot of actors claim that
they're fans but when you you know
follow up with them and preston they'll
be like well my kids love the
spider-man's and they told me it's cool
but is it true you know that you carry
around a notebook filled with mcu facts
do you have it on hand i love it this
thing goes everywhere with me
i think this is um kevin feige's biggest
fear this notebook don't let that out of
your sight
no i'm like terrified of like leaving it
somewhere and then everyone's just like
finding my deepest darker secrets
no but um
it's funny so the first time i met kevin
was over zoom
and i was just hyperventilating and then
go to production and they're like okay
kevin's coming up wednesday and it's
monday and he comes and i just like
stared at him until he left i couldn't
verbalize words or be a human at all and
so i had written this like four page
letter in case i wasn't able to talk
again and the first page was like me
gushing over him the next three were
like
70-something questions i had about him
in the mcu like
how much hours of sleep he gets and like
things about the fandom in general and
and he like called me the next day and
answered the first 40. and so the rest
of the questions that he hasn't heard
are in here and every time i get the
opportunity
so why did you do this
i mean you were never allowed to get to
the end of that list i want you to just
keep asking him questions because i
think you're giving him ideas you're
giving them great ideas i'm sure for the
future i i like to think so
i love it i have on standby my notebook
that i bring into movie screenings like
whenever i go
what
literally every time new projects are
announced i'm like oh my god all the
work that these guys have to do you know
are you are you doing okay are you
getting sleep
that is so sweet of you to ask me that
like i'm uh
that's so kind of you i think that just
happened and i'm like these guys
no
no sleep for the gods no rest for the
weary i you know look this is a labor of
love here in new rock stars and i'm so
honored to be able to do what we do and
to have this as a job and like i think
the only downside is
you know
when i go watch movies it i do have to
bring this notebook and i am scribbling
the whole time and like i'm not allowed
to like take my eyes off the screen so i
use my thumb to just like keep my place
in a dark movie theater and i'm like i'm
close to the end of the page i'm writing
on my pants now so i have to flip uh so
it is work but like i don't know it's i
can't complain about my job being to
watch uh hilarious awesome
shows like ms marvel and
and everything else um i also wanted to
ask uh you if just to make sure it's
okay you know you've done a ton of
interviews like it's crazy you know for
prepping for this interview i'm like
watching you on jimmy fallon or on the
daily show and i'm like
well i'm not jimmy fallon i'm not trevor
noah but i am uh a youtube nerd and i
feel like i want to get your permission
is it okay if we just geek out about the
mcu for the rest of this interview yes
please
i was honestly
i did jimmy fallon i did all of those
but i was like most nervous for this one
because i
know you can't well you're gonna ask and
i like have so much respect for you and
like this entire channel it's a weird
full circle moment
but yeah let's do it for this interview
we're now an honorary new rock source
co-host so welcome welcome we we got
someone on the inside of the mcu so
welcome back to the dungeon
yeah i need to help my name
if it didn't smell so bad after a week
of comic-con coverage i would be wearing
it now um but um okay let's talk about
miss marvel and spoiler warning for
anyone who hasn't had the delightful
opportunity to watch ms marvel in that
those six episodes they are so much fun
please go watch them uh and enjoy them
because this show has everything like i
had no idea how many corners of the mcu
this show would touch on and and what it
means to be a nerd and uh we got to
start with the big one so in the finale
episode you were established as the
first mutant that's identified in the
mcu and i assume you saw the comic con
announcements this past weekend no
mutants so far announced on the schedule
but we assume they're coming i assume
you can't talk too much uh really at all
about where we might see mutants next
but i just want to ask you as a fan of
all this where do you want to see
mutants show up next oh
god i don't even know we didn't even
know that scene was even going to make
the cut we shot it not knowing if it was
going to happen
like i got sent that script before
reshoots for our show started
and i was freaking out emailing everyone
texting everyone in all caps i was like
this is happening please tell me i'm
like a mutant um and we we shot it we
were like still crossing our fingers
hoping it was going to make the cut and
it did and it was literally all up to
kevin it was
literally how this happened was son our
producer was in one of the writer room
meetings and she's like
what if we like
we can't figure this out like what if we
just made her a mutant or something kim
was like okay and
that's it
so i don't know what their plans are
i would love to see just like more you
know mutants pop up and a you know name
wars coming just just a lot of
people established as mutants and then
eventually we get some sort of x-men
team up together that'd be awesome
absolutely yeah i i think it seems to be
the plan you know watching multiverse of
madness we were like okay well they have
patrick stewart coming in and maybe
that's the way they're gonna do it but
then two minutes later we're like i
guess not uh but
i like this approach of just
establishing characters like you who are
just who have that genetic
predisposition i think that's like a
more organic way to go and i'm glad that
you get to be part of it i know what an
honor i mean like especially working
with sonna and knowing like you know
they wanted to make her an um a mutant
in the first place and it was a weird
time in comics so it didn't happen but
uh it's it's so exciting and and
everyone i couldn't get any takes where
i wasn't giggling except the one that we
saw in disney plus literally every
single time matt said the word i i had
to break it was just like
too good to be true
yeah iman i loved the way you delivered
it too like you did this thing that
sometimes if you watch like outtakes
from saturday night live some actors uh
will to keep from breaking will go
that's literally well the closest we
could get we not break
it was so wonderful
i'm so excited to see them like cut it
all together like all my terrible
outtakes of me just like laughing
oh it was terrible and matt did such a
good job and just saying the word and i
couldn't say the word in real life for
the longest time until like recently i
kept calling it the m word it's just
give me chills
yeah well the m word can mean anything
in the mcu right like we have mephisto
we have a house of m you know the m word
has so many i am so excited that
mephisto actually comes into the mcu oh
greater than your birthday oh me too
yeah
i think i'll have to change my birthday
to that date you know when he arrives
um okay so it's interesting to hear how
that came about i assumed something like
that had happened because it's
interesting when you watch the episode
this scene almost feels like a
post-credits scene it comes after we
have this moment where it's going to be
yeah we like
it it just felt too good we needed to
you know like kind of keep people
watching before sure the actual
post-credits scene so yeah it totally
was meant to be one and it felt like
this nice coda with uh bruno and aki i
love that nakia gets the mean girls
reference with the shawarma worked in it
was like my favorite joke that episode
but do you have any uh insight into what
might have been in bruno's note because
we never saw what was on the note that
he put in your locker that's a great
question we did have so that that last
lamppost shot that you saw we did have a
version where it's kamala reading the
note
that that bruno left for her and they
had written this this like fake note for
me but they didn't show me what it was
until i read it so i would get all
emotional or whatever
um
but i i think that's something we're
gonna explore in season two if that
happens i hope it happens i think all
these characters have a lot of story
left to tell
um but yeah i maybe it's bruno's you
know
just pouring his soul out and then
confessing his love for kamala who knows
yeah that'd be great uh so talking about
that post-credits scene it you know it's
been confirmed that uh kamala and carol
danvers by the producers uh that they
did swap places we also learned that the
director of the marvels nia acosta
actually shot that scene which which we
speculated it felt like it had a
slightly different vibe to it did you
know when he shot that scene
where kamala might be transported to
what did they tell you what's happening
in that moment
and again you can plead the fifth you
don't have to say too much because i
know it ties in with the next movie we
did shoot that in the marvels not during
miss marvel so i do know the story
because i was in the movie
but um yeah they did switch places
where did she go
we'll find out in a year okay i can't
wait to find out you know we're looking
for clues or just a sense of context i
like how carol says oh no no no and runs
away and the way i read that is she's
like worried where come where this fan
of her might now be
um like can you at least give us a sense
of what kamala's initial emotional
reaction when she arrives somewhere new
or even you could just like make a face
into like what how she might be feeling
where she is now oh god
a lot of
fear and excitement at the same time of
where she ends up
that's that's what i'll say uh all right
i will make 12 theory videos about that
answer
i wanted to ask you uh oh actually let's
do a little segment here called that i'm
just gonna call it debunk devos this is
where uh you know i have there's some
questions about how exactly kamala's
powers come from her mutation because
obviously introducing her as a mutant
seems like an answer to a question but
she has the nor light she has the bangle
she has the x gene all three seem to be
necessary and my explanation on this and
i i kind of want you to debunk this uh
but like
i'm thinking that the the mutant gene
might be the lock mechanism her family
history with the nord dimension might be
on the other side of that locked door
the source of her power and the bangle
is the key that unlocks the lock to open
the door is that the case do you think
specific to kamala khan or do you think
this could be a way to describe all
mutants in the mcu going forward i
i feel like it's specific to kamala i
think you're on the right track with it
because we never really fleshed out just
because we didn't know if it was the
scene was actually going to happen but i
made many theory boards prior to filming
because i was so confused
um
the way i justify it to myself is like
yes the bangle unlocks her
x gene i think her actual mutant power
is the ability to facilitate the nor
so she is part gin
and she's for human
but she can do what comrade can't like i
don't think carmen's a huma a mutant
because he can't harness the nord the
way that kamala does you can't like
control it the way she does and i say i
think that's kind of her power yeah
that's kind of what i'm going with that
that her ability to kind of make shapes
out of it is like the main part like
like armor from the x-men
it's it's a very similar vibe i think
that's kind of what inspired you know
the the way we animated kamala yeah i
like that i like that there has to be
some kind of like biological component a
like a muscle memory that you're
reconnecting with in order to be fully
mutant i like that approach um
but she can't use her powers rather than
angle because a lot of people were like
oh the bangle is what like lets her use
her powers i i do think it's just
something that unlocked it
and hopefully we'll get to see her
without the bangle using her powers yeah
i like that too i like the bengal is
almost like a spark plug it's just kind
of it's what gets it all started but
it's not a battery that's continuing
continuing to power it
right actually i wanted to ask about
that moment one of my favorite moments
from the season is when waleed explains
the noir dimension we see this awesome
holographic map display of the
dimensions architecture there's like a
tree and you know me i'm like going
frame by frame through that i want to
ask you as someone who shot that scene
what did you see like what was in the
script what nothing
nothing
dude it was like four led lights in a
circle
[Laughter]
and they're like this thing's happening
and we're like where do we look they're
just like in the middle but not like
down but like kind of up but not too
high just like in the general
middle and there's like a map and
because a lot of this the times we don't
always have previouses to like see what
it looks like for for scenes where it's
like not fight scenes and so it was just
using your imagination be like oh yeah
this is what the newer dimension looks
like
okay
cool
yeah it's it's weird it's it's mostly
just led lights even calls powers the
way we film it is like i'm standing on
plexiglass and we shine purple light
underneath it i love it and anytime i i
hear answers like this it just blows my
mind that
you as actors are able to make this look
so believable like you are reacting to
it in the moment it just feels like i
don't know like i took some acting
classes in college but i don't think i
could ever believably go on a green
screen set and be like this is actually
something i'm holding or looking at i
honestly it wasn't that hard if you ask
the right questions
especially with the powers because this
is such a new power set and something we
haven't seen in the mcu yet and so it's
stressful because everything we
establish now is going to be canon for
the rest of the mcu and so we have to be
really careful about like you know my
physicality and whatever you know
how we manifest this how difficult is it
for kamala to you know make these shapes
how what does it look like what does it
feel like and so just sitting down with
your vfx people asking all these
questions and then they come up with
these pre-visualizations of what the
scenes are going to look like so it
gives you a bit of an idea because it's
like a cartoon version of what it's
going to look like for real
and
yeah but otherwise it's just really
awkward and it's dead silent on stage
and you're just like this pretending
like you're saving people's lives i mean
i think that's such a smart question to
ask of how it feels like how hard is it
to do this because yeah there are
moments where it seems to burden or
strain kamala to be making these shapes
which is just interesting to watch for
sure i want to ask you about time travel
a major twist in the series
molly goes back in time to the 40s
during the partition to cast a trail of
stars and that is the historical trail
of stars that saved her own grandmother
um and you know the the time travel
eggheads here call this like a causal
loop or predestination but did you have
questions for how the logic of this time
travel fits in with what we saw in
avengers end game or in loki
yup first thing i asked i'm like doesn't
this break all the rules and they're
like
oh we'll figure that out
i think the marvel's is gonna explain it
a little more to be fair
god i want to tell you things but this
is going to be on youtube
it's okay it's fine i understand it's
totally good i don't want to get you in
any trouble i i do think you know
god no i can't i can't in a year hey
please call me back
i absolutely we're going to talk more
about this on the other side of it but i
think one thing that we can at least
infer from these uh phase five and six
announcements is that you know kang is
really the future of the mcu and i think
one thing if you one interpretation of
loki could suggest that all of this was
pre-scripted
at least by he remains or some other
variant of kang and i just wanted to ask
like do you think it's possible
and this is just nerd speculation you
know if you can't speculate on it
without in bringing in what you already
know do you think kang or he remains
might have planned specifically for
kamala to go back in time
yeah okay so the inscription on the
bengal used to be what is destined for
you will come for you we did change it
after that but i like to use that as a
way of you know justifying how kamal
goes back in time and and why that was
meant to happen because there were so
many questions and we really wanted to
bring partition in the story and just
i know it's cramming a lot in episodes
four and five but you know we didn't
know if we were gonna have season two
and we had to put all our cars on the
table and just like show everything
about this culture and and you know the
history of it and so
that line was destined for you will come
for you that used to be on the bengals
kind of a good
sense of you know this was meant to
happen predestination even if it kind of
hurts the end game time travel rules but
so does old steve rogers so exactly
exactly you know you know how it works
so yeah kevin feige is the king of this
universe that's how i like to i think so
too i think it's some point we need an
easter egg where kevin feige can just be
revealed as the one above all or one of
the kang variants or something like that
no um
he knows actually you bring up like i
loved learning about the the history of
the partition i think it was referenced
in some high school history class i took
but it's not something that's that's
talked enough about i'm so glad that
this show could go into that and and
humanize it in in this beautiful way and
i i honestly i have to confess what you
seek is seeking you was my favorite line
of this of this mini series and like
once and i have to also say i initially
interpreted it as oh it's like a warning
like
the person you're hunting down is going
to stab you in the backs to watch your
back and then the next episode my heart
melted when it was contextualized as
what you just described this sense of
destiny that your deepest hopes and
desires are just as eager to find their
way to you you know this this
line from roomie the sufi poet and
mystic and i honestly i'm writing my
wedding vows right now and i almost put
that line in but i thought it might be a
little hokey but i want to ask you was
there any line or scene in the series
that was especially meaningful for you
oh
um
the first time in episode three it's not
even like that
momentous of the scene i mean i guess it
is the first time kamala uses her big in
hand at the wedding after bruno
breaks his arm
so we we had like two takes to film that
and
there there was a version where we set
him big in but it didn't feel right in
that moment but it was it was the first
time that we see her in begin properly
and i just i wanted to get it right and
we had two takes to do it and son our
producer she's on set every day and i
just i only care about her approval
and so like
we do the shot and it was really like
annoying technically because
all the action scenes are just so
exaggerated to look better on camera and
you know it's not how you naturally
would punch just because you know we
need to go this way and leave some space
in the frame for the big fist and so it
was really hard and and i thought i did
a really shitty job and then i was like
crying and sono after just like came up
to me was really proud and it looked
really good and it just felt really good
and watching it felt really good and so
that like little moment just all the
little comic booky moments i i just
appreciated a lot
even even seeing partition it was one of
the most stressful things to film just
because it felt so real and we were in
thailand in the middle of the night it
was like 40 degrees it was terrible we
had costume changes midday because we
would sweat through our costumes and so
that entire scene was also like really
emotional for a lot of people
but yeah i honestly the entire show
just had moments where
either from the comics or from my
culture i i definitely re like embrace
my culture a lot more now after filming
the show which is crazy yeah i think
it's been like an enlightening
experience for everyone watching this
show just to learn both about uh like
the culture of karachi and then as well
as like jersey city and what it means to
just spend an afternoon shopping with
your mom like i thought it was so
beautiful all right i gotta ask you i
read the reddit ama where you said that
after you said the mcu wouldn't be 616
on the red carpet that i guess kevin
feige saw you the next day and stared
you down and just went like
and walked away
i
think about that every day
it's
okay i get it i get it i get he makes
decisions that's fine he's done a great
job i'm just trying to you know it's
convenience you now you have to specify
comics one six versus mcu-616 and i'm
just trying to save everyone's breath
you know
like it's a lot
yeah kevin just doesn't like
nine nine nine
and i don't blame him there's too many
nines to say you don't you lose track of
your nines three nines in so i i get it
616 i think is a nice clear slate but it
does require further explanation you
know you have to like remind people well
then the movies are an adaptation of the
comics as opposed to a universe
alongside them um
does all of this
think about it which is why i disagreed
with the 616.
but yeah well
i can't do anything about it
after going through this process you're
now in the midst of it does it give you
a greater appreciation for how the execs
build this universe or do you think it's
still like something can be mcu canon if
enough fans believe it to be true are
you still clinging to that oh
that's a good one okay well i
there are a lot of things that are
planned so
far ahead and you don't even realize
until things just click and you're like
oh this is a moment where you can bring
back this from this movie and it's just
incredible how these guys like come up
with this stuff and and you know try to
tie all the pieces together and then
there's a lot of seeds that we plant
that we don't have plans for and then
like five years down the line they'll be
like oh remember that let's do that it's
like i honestly like iron man 2 and just
like having the little name warren and
wakanda references on the map i feel
like that was never planned but i don't
know but now it's you know coming into
play and it's awesome seeing how many
easter eggs that weren't even planted
and you guys made
just out of thin air
it's amazing especially now being a part
of this and then watching your
breakdowns and be like oh we didn't even
plan that but did that work you can take
credit for it you can absolutely take
credit and that's what's just so cool
about what growing up with the mcu is
seeing little like atlantis references
in the middle of the ocean on a map and
then now they can pay it off like 10
years later it's just really exciting
and then i guess the last thing i want
to ask you yeah we know that peter
parker's on youtube i have a theory that
he's just posting under an anonymous
account like the videos that he
self-records of himself is there a
chance that peter parker and kamala khan
might have come across each other's
content kamala's got her youtube channel
i'm sure i'm sure i would love to see
them like just talk about that and be
like wait i subscribe to yours too
um
yeah
that that'd be fun i think they they had
such fun vibes in the comics as well and
those team-ups were one of my favorites
hopefully we'll see it soon well we will
leave it there but uh iman thank you so
much it was such a delight to be able to
meet you and to chat with you and i i
can't wait to chat with you more after
we see you next in the mcu yes i have so
much to spell because like i want to
tell you you're wrong about things but i
can't tell you what you're wrong about
until it hurts until i'm proven wrong
thank you for this
i think that's the trick you know
well thank you again iman i just want to
say thank you and keep up the great work
thank you you too get some sleep so that
was our interview with the amazing iman
valani kamala khan ms marvel if you
haven't seen the episodes of miss marvel
yet what are you waiting on it's so
great and next summer iman belani will
join brie larson and tiona paris in the
marbles thank you for joining us you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
you